[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome to the mit center for art
science and technology's 2021 symposium
unfolding intelligence the art and
science of contemporary computation
cast was established in 2012 with the
goal of building and building on
connections between the worlds of art
science and technology
this is the third in a series of
symposia the cast has convened since
then and as with its predecessors
we bring together artists scientists
engineers and humanists
from within mit and from the world at
large to discuss
areas of rapidly evolving research and
urgent social relevance
and defined in that dialogue stimulation
confirmation
provocation intersection and we hope
common purpose at mit
cast partners with departments labs and
centers to integrate the arts across the
curriculum
to enrich and encourage artistic
collaboration and to provide support to
faculty and members of the mit community
as they pursue their own artistic
practice
and or research in addition to symposia
like this
cass facilitates the sharing of this
creative work beyond the institute
by producing concerts exhibitions and
publications
and making them available to the public
so thank you for being with us today we
hope you will join us throughout the
week at virtual events addressing the
aesthetic
technical and critical issues pertaining
to artificial intelligence
and computational media we also
look forward to seeing you on friday
april 9th as the symposium culminates
with a live interactive event to which
all attendees are invited
and which you can join presenters and
artists in breakout rooms
to explore hidden threads between all
that has been discussed
this week
welcome to the q a panel for
deep time and intelligence my name is
will and i'll be moderating the
discussion today
we have with us uh four brilliant
speakers who i
i'm i hope all of you have had a chance
to
listen to over the weekend uh their
talks from
marcus buehler holly herndon gary
tomlinson and antonio tralba
were a true pleasure and before we
get into my opening remarks synthesizing
some of those
uh fabulous contributions and kicking us
off on this
hour-long discussion i just have a few
thank yous really
bringing together this kind of group to
create uh an encounter between arts
sciences and humanities requires uh an
enormous
amount of work so first to uh my my
fellow conveners
caroline jones stephan helmreich and fox
horrell thank you and
i hope all of you in the audience have
the opportunity to
listen in on their conversations and as
well and uh join
us in in discussions with uh all the
speakers that they have
brought to bear on this um discussion of
info unfolding intelligence and also to
the cast producers to uh dana and heidi
and catherine and leah
and lydia and harry and all the work
they've done supporting us
in the background organizing the
communications and logistics with
today's events and
contributing to the beautiful website
that they've created that i hope you all
have time to dig deeper on uh in
engaging with us in
in these discussions and also to jen
and lucy um for providing asl
interpretation today
um very much appreciated so without
further ado
i'll move to my opening remarks and we
can
see the the the rest of the panelists
with us here today
deep time and intelligence
if there were a single thread that i
felt knit together these three
fascinating talks on sound
time and the formation of intelligence
across scales and modes of existence
i would have to hone in on the concept
of variety
the question of variation is a
fascinating one clearly central to
gary's attempt to define
radical niche construction by
sensitizing
us to the pervasive plasticity of nice
construction
in that context of inquiry i was able to
sense
the core of the key semiotic information
concept when gary spoke
of a bird listening and singing as a
varied complexity
of the world proportionate to the varied
complexity of the brain architectures
thereby enlivened to react to reach
after clarity with respect to a
genuinely semiotic
variety here would have to enliven a
sense in us
not only of the emergence selection and
optimization of a function
say for addition or vocalization
or for auditory feature detection but a
sense of the plasticity
of niche constructions that take place
through a mind that can
relive the relation of interior variety
to exterior variety the sound of
birdsong
in this light sounds by which a bird
does not merely fulfill a reproductive
function but rather relives a relation
to not only another bird but to the
variety of
song senses and throws a voice from that
vocal commons in a new direction
recast the tone of another let's say
play with
in and through the plasticity of the
niche
learning to sense that plasticity to
respect it a feat of reflection
surely and one i believe the question of
ai training practices can help us think
about
i would be curious to hear gary's
thoughts uh
and thoughts on his talk that would help
us listen for the hints of when it is
that ai
forces us into thinking clearly about
the genuinely meaningful
does ai open up such a space of
reflection on variation
or does it lock us into a thought of the
functional
perhaps before we ask is a.i as smart as
it be
i want to hear in gary's final
provocation a questioning that enlists
us
asking have we in entertaining gary's
reanimation of the mental world of birds
and bees
found our thoughts wandering to a
thought or relation to ai
that sees the maintenance of a
differentiation of the functional
from the meaningful at work curious then
to listen to holly and marcus
fascinating that both of you
also named bach when discussing this
concern over variation
one of the central concerns in training
ai systems to sing and play
is that they not reproduce in ai systems
aesthetic cul-de-sacs as holly put it
but how practically to avoid that i know
that marcus is very interested in using
midi data to train his ai
and that holly and marcus both have
different approaches
to using either midi or audio data in
their training sets
so i was also just wondering simply if
antonio had thoughts on generating and
designing audio trainees
training sets and what stakes that
technical decision has
in preserving or shaping data into
something that generates desirable
results
what is a desirable result then a
surprise
an optimal performance a novel or
meaningful variation
taking this thread of data set
generation back to radical plasticity
with holly's differentiation of sampling
from spawning
i heard an important distinction being
drawn one that would force us to rethink
the plasticity of the niche
in the economic context of the digital
music marketplace
i was inspired by holly's phrase when
she pointed out
that we must remain attuned to the
entitlement to a shared musical past
when building datasets would it be
generative to invoke the concept of
niche
and then infuse the plasticity of same
with stakes
cultural political and ethical aesthetic
does ai help us think about the mutable
plasticity of the sonic commons in other
words
scene ownership and niche production
seem
to complement and trouble each other
here and i would love to hear further
thoughts
in the vein of this role of ai in
shaping a reflection on or even staging
a very
variation in scene construction or
constriction
the idea of variation for marcus seemed
to hinge on the idea that ai can add new
information
in his case working with molecular
dynamics simulation
that information would be generated by
computers trained on the archaic memory
of primordial forces at work in protein
folding
those forces adding to and reconfiguring
data
presented to our machines from the
musical archive here then
dataset creation comes into dialogue
with data generation and also points to
the mathematical and scientific
constraints
placed on information generation
professor taralba too
in his comments on the manual
manipulation of gan generated images
touches on the concept of variation when
he suggests that neural nets have
imaginations
in the history of philosophy and poetry
the variation of images in the
imagination was famously called upon by
locke and hobbes and hume blake and
coleridge
and made to point of a contention
are those variations always
concatenations of sensory and preference
impressions primary and secondary
qualities or properties of matter
reconfigured by the brain or are
there forms derived from the mind or
spirit that intervene
and shape that raw material of variation
with the manual addition of grass
neurons to dome drawing neurons
those questions somehow become more
concrete less
binary in the hylomorphism of mind and
matter
while we could localize the function
grass
even in a single artificial neuron those
localized manipulations produce results
that seem to imply
a network of other related functions
like on top
yellowish fuzzy gleaming in
seeing these in instances of
localization and neurons returning weird
results
condensing so many categories into a
pixel distribution
i was wondering if marcus or gary saw
something to trouble or confirm their
thoughts on properties versus processes
patterns of energy localization versus
plasticity set in motion
our neural nets unhinging us from the
object
from stable substrates configured into
materials
with properties and certainly i can
return to some of those questions
um and call on individuals but i will
perhaps leave the floor open to see what
reactions this might have
produced
holly i hear you i i see you smiling
would you would you would you care to
interject
um sure thanks so much for that overview
and thanks to all the panelists for your
really interesting and inspiring
presentations i really enjoyed getting
to learn about all of your work
um maybe i could just touch on some of
the things that you brought up
um i did i did kind of chuckle to myself
a little bit when i was watching
marcus's um presentation and he brought
up
bach because in my presentation of
course i'm using it as a criticism
um as you mentioned this kind of
aesthetic cul-de-sac you know
this idea that a lot of machine learning
research is
looking to kind of recreate forms of the
past but what i found
interesting about marcus's work is that
he's actually bringing in
other forms through the um the protein
structures in order to kind of open up
and
um and add new information to the bach
training set
so i think he avoids the aesthetic
cul-de-sac in a really interesting way
yeah there was a maybe i can add to this
a little bit i mean well thanks for the
great introduction and i
i took some notes and um there's a lot
of really really cool intersections that
you identified
but yeah i wanted to say that the what
what we do in the work we we're trying
to put um different levels of
information
um from different species or different
scales on a
on a platform where they can communicate
and we call it sometimes interspecies
communications when we talk about
spiders speaking with humans or in this
case
looking at data that's been generated
hundreds of years ago speaking with data
that's been generated over
billions of years during evolution and
we found that that transition into an
abstraction
whether be it mathematically rigorous
like in category theory or
using sound or coding into these audible
barcodes
the way to do that and what's
interesting is that then you have the
ability to use ai or computers as a way
of creating this
communication in a way that wouldn't be
possible otherwise because either the
the actors are have long been um are
long dead or
um they cannot talk to each other like
we cannot speak to spiders immediately
so i found sound to be a very effective
way for this abstraction
and um and adding new information is
something i would say we've done for
many
hundreds of thousands of years actually
but computers allow us to do this
in a perhaps most systematic way or
reaching observational levels that our
brain isn't wired for so i found really
interesting when
antonio was talking about you know
finding the neurons in particular layers
that grass in an image are great dome
structures and i
and i think that's a really interesting
mechanistic insight we can gain from
these neural nets that
it's really hard to pinpoint in our own
brain but we can't identify
these kinds of things in our own brain
very easily
yes so actually i can comment a little
bit on that so
i think that it's a it's very
interesting to see
what these ai systems are learning when
you
present them with training data and it
is true that there is a piece of it that
is about recreating
the past as what it was mentioning but
but in this representation that the
systems are
discovering which are not humans you
know humans are only
presenting the data to the the systems
but the representation
seems to be somewhat meaningful and this
is what allow us then to manipulate our
presentation and to put grass
in domes and so on and one thing that we
discovered
is that it's not just that there are
units that represent
particular concepts that emerge just
from the training procedure itself but
also these relationships as
uh you know as as it was mentioned in
the introduction the fact that grass
only goes on top
of certain surfaces that was something
that at the beginning it just seemed to
us
as being accidental but then we
discovered that there were
that actually the network was learning
all those relationships
for instance there are some units that
will
learn to draw doors but and now you can
manipulate them
and say where you want to have a door
but you cannot put a door anywhere
like if you have an image and you try to
put a door on the sky
the network will just not do it even
though you are activating the units that
draw
doors they will those activations will
not survive the rest of the process
and they will get cancelled out and the
network learns all these kinds of
relationships
and one interesting thing is that now
you can imagine a process
where you change the way that the
network
generates data so that it violates some
of these principles and starts
generating data
that looks somewhat real
but it doesn't isn't something that does
not necessarily exist
you can start putting things where it's
not possible
you can change the laws of light
transmission for instance you can one
thing that we notice is that whenever
there is a window
the system learns that there should be
some reflections
appearing on top of shiny surfaces but
you can change those rules
and start having reflections where there
are no windows or
reflections disappear when there are
windows and
and there are very simple changes that
you need to make
so one could imagine that eventually you
could generate data that
feels plausible but it's not real
and breaking that will detect that that
holy was mentioning at some point
may i may i leap in as well here the the
the presentations were all fascinating
will thank you so much for the for the
wonderful introduction
um the the question of of
grass on the top of the church is what i
want to return to
and and you know i thought antonio i
thought your
the the machine learning that was going
on there was absolutely fascinating
i really want to to press you to
understand exactly what it means to
think that there is
a single neuron so to speak that is the
grass neuron for example that has
learned
somehow because of course attuned
neurons are in biological systems are
absolutely fundamental the
the honeybee sucrose neuron for example
that i mentioned in in my presentation
is an example of that and the
sensitivity of it is is constantly in
plastic change in relation to in
relation to its environment
um but one of the things that's striking
about
those images that were generated by
machine generated images after this
learning process came up in the question
of the watermark that you mentioned
it is to me exactly the mark of the
difference between
a machine algorithm that has learned
certain things but doesn't know how to
contextualize its learning in an
environment
and a a biological mind the difference
is precisely in the fact that no
biological uh no human
taking all of those pictures and and
instructed to draw another picture would
include the watermarks and yet
the machine cannot but include the
watermarks unless instructed to do
differently
um where would you
yeah that's an interesting question
the machine realizes well realizes it
tries to reproduce the same data that
you give it to it
and watermarks are part of it watermarks
were not present in all of the images
but there was a percentage of them that
contain water marks so what happened is
that the network will produce
sometimes images with watermarks
and and in fact we located where those
water marks are generated
and it's not just one single unit
generally what you have is a small
population of units maybe 20 units out
of
500 that represent a particular object
and in particular watermarks there are
some units
that were doing those watermarks so now
you can for instance say
you know i want this unis to never be
active
and from that from that moment all of
the images that this process will
generate
will not contain watermarks or you could
reverse it and always have them active
and then all of the images will have a
watermark
so the the system doesn't have the
the the the knowledge of what this means
so for a human you know you could know
that the watermark is really not
important
and then decide not to put it ever but
the machine
the watermark or the door or a door they
are all equally important
so i can actually imagine oh sorry
please i was just thinking about the
watermark it
reminds me of kind of like net
expressions where artists began to
incorporate some of
these kind of aesthetics into their into
their own aesthetics so i could actually
imagine um a kind of um you know
human creative mind also integrating the
watermark but then that would of course
be through
a kind of human um understanding of
comedy or
you know the context would be entirely
different
yeah and you know in a certain sense the
context
that the word imagination came up at the
end of uh in regard to the grass on on
top of the church um
uh you know the human imagination
talking about deep time and intelligence
the human imagination
there's a wonderful phrase that
archaeology that an archaeologist
introduced 30 years ago
uh and that has been tracked in
archaeological proxies across
500 000 years of homonym evolution
long before homo sapiens came along and
the phrase is the release from proximity
that is the grant what gradually
unfolded in hominin intelligence
was the cap was the capacity to imagine
things that
weren't there that weren't in front of
the senses in some cases imagine things
that were
minimal counter intuitions as opposed to
what was actually seen in the
environment
in in more dramatic cases finally to
imagine things that never have existed
um and and of course humans are
fantastically good at this
this release from proximity is a
long-term evolutionary
thing that that hominins have come to be
able to do neanderthals were probably
pretty good at it too
um but certainly homo sapiens all homo
sapiens are great at it
um that seems to be different from
simply
manifesting something that never existed
through the machine learning that you're
talking about
and i think those you know those
differences this is not to underplay
the extraordinary achievement of these
neural nets that you put together this
is amazing it seems to me it's amazing
work
and yet the gap remains somehow between
what they're up to
and what a human imagination any human
imagination can be up to
maybe i can share a few thoughts on on
this follow him this is a brilliant
brilliant point um
thank you gary and also really to the
other ones
what we've been doing with
using data from original compositions
like bach
was to actually seek information that
might have been encoded in this data so
we used
midi data that's another discussion on
whether midi data versus audio data or
fluctuations of that
but but let's say we take that data and
we've been seeking
patterns within that data that holds
hidden messages
that the creator of this data bach in
this case or other people that might
have created music at the time
have encoded things in that data that
they weren't aware of right so
i'd like to hear actually gary's
thoughts on this um on
what the the context might be from
perspective on this
this was another level of human
imagination not just things that aren't
there but imagining things
unconsciously that were there in the
past but have that have been forgotten
right so these
structures about protein folding
internal structures in the organs
were known at the time when bach created
the music yet we've shown that there are
structures in the music he created
that resemble biological systems that
have been evolving over billions of
years in the evolution of proteins for
instance
you know i i mean i i don't have of
course i don't know marcus i yeah
i don't have any full answer to such a
broad and wonderful question
um and the kinds of questions that are
raised by by what you've been what
you've been working on
um and yet
um the what you what you have what you
are demonstrating it seems to me is the
continuity
across across cosmic dimensions of
course i have a phone call coming in
right now i just turned off my phone
sorry about that
um the the continuity across even cosmic
dimensions and at all scales
spatial and temporal scales um of of
vibrational essences right uh the
those vibrational essences are in
themselves manifesting at least a
rudimentary structure right
the the notion of vibration is a
structure it seems to me
a process at the same time and a dynamic
structure but a structure
and so so to to begin to under unfold
the the continuity across all those
degrees of
of scale the continuity between um
that kind of uh structure and the
structures that human minds
come up with um you know uh will uh
mentioned in his introduction
song and of course i mentioned i talk
about birdsong
i am constantly wanting to say that
of course we call it birdsong of course
we humans do all kinds of things with
this but to call it song at
all is probably a misnomer as long as we
are doing
as long as we are imposing human uh some
general sense of of the human value in
song
on onto those sonic structures but they
are immensely complex sonic structures
immensely communicative sonic structures
in complex social systems and all of it
then comes back to
to the sense you know this well
the vibrational sense that you were
working with so
so my question for you marcus would be
once you have translated for example
the the arya to the goldberg variations
once you've translated it
through the filter of amino acid
vibrational
dynamics um well two things um
it doesn't come back as the aria
that bach composed even though we could
hear traces of that arya said we could
hear echoes here and there
um it comes back as something very very
different um but why doesn't it come
back as something even
further even more different even more
radically different haven't you
converted some of these amino acid
dynamics into a set of pitches that is
after all a very very small subset of
all the frequencies that we hear
right yeah correct i think maybe also
that in responding to that
i'm i'm curious to to um
[Music]
configure the questions slightly to
maybe bring us back to
um a question that's coming through um
in in the back channel chats right now
is that
when we're having these discussions
about
um whether it is merely a function
or some kind of meaning or whether it is
a genuine variation
or something that repeats a difference
that's already encoded in the data set
i'm curious is if as practicing
scientists and artists if you find
yourself
developing an intuitive sense of how to
negotiate those questions
in the choices that you're making as
practitioners so
when you're searching for a genuine
variation
what kinds of techniques or choices are
you making when
are you confronted with those almost
ontological
conundrums um through the work that
you're generating and i think that that
that has to do with um the the aesthetic
choices that maybe marcus would be uh
confronted with in seeing this new
variation of the arya and
having to decide you know whether to
perhaps change the the
the force equation that he's using to
model the protein fold or
or for for holly in in building these
file systems of all these different
variations that you showed us on these
audio files uh
negotiating somehow with like what the
basic
building blocks of a composition are as
they're they're they're derived from
this engagement with machine learning
systems so
yeah i'm really curious in gary's
question too but i think that that
that dimension of um of of practice is
something that the audience is curious
in
hearing more about
that was that was that was directed i i
i i had understood particularly at
marcus
i didn't want to put it on or holly
they're not like or
professor turaba is also engaged in the
practice of building data sets as well
so i'm i'm curious if those
if the if that if that uh that you know
well i can maybe i can briefly answer
and then let everyone else also say
something but
there are a lot of choices of course we
make um and i would say
a little bit to the question of gary and
the generalization that will talk about
the um we choose of course the universe
or the platform we're building
let's say the sounds from and in this
case we're working with the amino acids
and actually in the in the case of the
deep area that we
created um we're actually working not in
the innate amino acid scale but in a in
a in
in an equal temperament scaling to
reflect back what bach actually
originally intended the music to sound
like so we make a lot of choices in this
and that's a discussion that's much
longer in in what are the
more abstract ways to to to to look at
that and i think your birth song example
actually reminded me of that
when we do listen to proteins or
structures like this in the innate
vibrational spectrum we have a hard time
understanding them and accessing them in
our brain because we're not attuned to
these these ways of thinking or
listening
um so we are trying to make choices that
make it accessible to certain regions
um i would say that we want to make
interpolations similar to an expansion
in a series a taylor expansion where we
want to look at a reference point in
this case the aria and the original way
it's played in equal temperament
and then extrapolate from there a little
bit out
what would this additional information
from protein folding add to this
this structure so um so we can make
those choice
and we can go um either very far away or
we can stay reasonably close in this
piece that i presented in the
in the exam in the presentation um there
was a compromise between going too far
um but also being able like you say to
recognize fragments of it and that's
what i wanted to show is there are these
fragments you can recognize them
but they're also differences and
distinctions which are very clear and
they tell the story of what this deep
time memory really brings to us
so it's not the computer alone doing it
i think will had that that that point
when we discussed
and i and i and i also mentioned this in
the in my talk
um you know in in the rendering of the
actual final product
there are many choices we make as humans
um and that's oftentimes misunderstood
right you have these
um algorithms that um create songs and
and i think holly mentioned some of
those some of those things in her talk
as well
um there are a lot of choices of course
that we need to make
and we're very far away from and maybe
perhaps infinitely far away from letting
it completely be automated by an
[Music]
algorithm
for me as a composer practitioner i my
ultimate goal is i'm i'm trying to
create meaning through the artwork that
i'm making so it's a kind of
meaning making a search um and so
as um as marcus mentioned you can't
really outsource that
to a machine um really i see machine
learning techniques as a way to augment
my process
particularly ideally a performance
an embodied performance practice that's
where i really think
things will get interesting and start to
to take off when we're able to as humans
music with other humans and machines in
kind of concert together that's when i
think
new new aesthetic possibilities and new
ideas will emerge and so that's what i'm
primarily focusing on right now i
haven't been focusing so much on
kind of um you know the statistical
analysis of certain existing forms and
trying to kind of
create new forms from that um so that's
another reason why i really um
tried to focus on using audio material
rather than
midi data because there's so you know as
as a sound artist and composer i find
so much um so many kind of sensual
qualities
in sound um as material um and for me
um a kind of midi representation of
of a piece is missing out on so many of
the things that i
that i find sensual about music um so
trying to kind of
understand what might be sensual about
one sound source and then trying to
understand how i might then
augment my performance practice to be
able to perform through that sound
that's been kind of my approach um to to
remain in the kind of driver's seat of
of of composer and meaning maker
yeah i think there is also something
interesting about
with respect to the choices that we make
there are choices at so many levels you
know the the data that we use
to train our system the representation
that we use
whether it's media or the raw audio
and also the architecture that we use to
process that data
and the choices that we don't make we
still make them
we are just not aware of them so
that's that's where all the biases come
in that
you know clip into our systems that we
might not be aware of them but the
system is just trying to reproduce what
it sees
and it's limited by the architecture and
the representational power that it has
given the choices that you made on how
you implement that a particular approach
so all of these things have an impact on
the results that you have and the
behavior that you have on
when you use a particular system
a phrase of yours uh antonio that came
up in your earlier comments
not all of the variations survived the
rest of the process
was very fascinating to me that you
could manually manipulate with something
in the system that you're using to
generate a variation
but that the system seems to have
implicit constraints
built into it that is something that i
also
you know reminded me of of of marcus's
approach in in the sense that there are
limitations or or constraints on the
the kinds of data that he can generate
and that's
has an interesting creative effect on
the work that working within limitations
is one of the interesting aspects
of the new kinds of creative processes
that are that are at work here
it's almost that we know about rule
constrained art making practices from
conceptual art for example
but we're operating with uh with a
different set of limitations
here ones that we may not even be able
to explicitly identify if if all of the
rules governing the net are not
completely transparent to us so i'm
curious if
these thoughts on the kind of uh the
kinds of limitation
setting um role of ai
uh have have have been um
whether those have been of interest to
you as uh as researchers and
and whether you wonder about what
constrains the validity of results in
these sorts of systems whether it be
scientifically or aesthetically
yeah i think that um the way that i see
current ai systems uh especially the
ones using neural networks i think it's
been true
maybe for a long time but especially
through nowadays
is that we have the systems that are
composed of very simple operations
and they have to through these simple
operations and recombining them
no they have to produce some complicated
tasks now they have to solve some
complicated tasks
and it is it each iteration of the
process
i see it as a as a filter and a stage
where you remove undesired
sources of variation and a recombination
stage where you try to find new concepts
from the data or build a more
sophisticated representation
but that recombination process is very
simple so
the way that you build a complex
representation is by
removing undesired sources of variation
and recombining the concepts a little
bit
and then removing again undesired
sources of variation in this new space
and recombining again and so on and
that's how the process evolves and this
is why you meet you need
like a lot of different stages of
processing and in the case of the brain
or you have all the neural
all the all the different layers of of
neurons that process the data
just moving one step towards you know
whatever task you want to solve at the
end whatever representation you want to
build
and i think that is is we are very
interested in trying to
see how much of that representation and
the way that the representation get
transformed is understandable by us
and i think that some part of it will be
understandable and there are some other
pieces that will not
and that maybe are not because they are
not really based on rules
necessarily but are a little bit more
intuitive now let's say
but i think that there is a big piece of
it that will be understandable
that's my personal belief and i think
that
from the artistic point of view i think
that is very interesting then once you
have these representations and if you
understand some of the rules
how do you break them and and what are
what are the things that you get out
and i think that things like abstract
art and so on are maybe
you know representations that preserve
rules to some level
of that processing but they don't go any
further you don't try to
recombine those things to get at the end
like real objects
you are just stopping very early on
and try to see okay how does the
representation look like at this level
um i i i want to leap in here and and
and push a little bit further on that
word representation it's a word that is
used by cognitivists all the time it's
one of those words
that i have trouble with because it's
rarely defined as clearly as it might be
a mental representation this is a phrase
that recurs over the last 40 years
everywhere and um we still have very
little
well we have ideas about what a mental
representation might be
and indeed it comes down to something
that looks it seems to come down to
something that looks antonio a little
bit like
what it is coming down to precisely in
in the in the algorithmic neural nets
that you're
that you're that are learning in your in
your work um
uh but boy
here's where my imagination fails me to
get from there
to what it is that that allows me to put
together
a whole elaborate context that tells me
in
in in trying to draw a picture that
answers to 50 pictures that you've shown
me
that i don't need to include the
watermark for example that it seems to
me is is
is uh is is a huge leap beyond what
machine learning
is is doing to this point and you know
uh
will focus in his remarks on my
presentation focus
on the question of plasticity and the
relationship between organism and
environment
um you know genes are not what we once
thought them to be it turns out
genes are not blueprints they they they
are in fact uh they are in fact
uh interacting at all moments with the
environment on all scales um down to the
momentary scale in fact in terms of
which genes can be expressed at a moment
at a moment's notice in in order to
direct
behavior so they have a directive
executive function and yet
that function is nothing like a stable
blueprint nothing like it at all
so in that sense intelligence itself
can't be localized in either a machine
or in my brain
intelligence is localized only in the
process
that extends from my brain
out to the whole environment or from the
machine out to the whole environment
and so the gist of my talk finally was
to ask whether
whether machine learning is coming
anywhere close to that kind of
of of hugely varied on all scales um
interrelation and hugely complex
interrelation between environment and
and uh and machine
um
so well let me let me say one thing but
i think that one missing piece
is the embodiment and
so current ai systems are not embodied
or you're poorly embodied
and i think that is um you know the case
of the watermark
why where where are watermarks important
it is it is really
because many other things that are
outside of the picture there is
there are other social implications that
go outside of what the picture
contains and and ai systems
generally they focus on on few sensory
modalities not like we've been talking
about audio you have images there is
also the tactile word
world but is when you put all these
things together that you start
grounding things and you still have
these limitations you're still
even when you have multi multiple
sensory modalities you will still have
some other choices to make but i think
that it provides an additional grounding
that
systems now don't really have
is not that the research community is
not aware of that
they are aware of it it's just that it
takes time to get there
and it's i think many of the advances
that we are seeing now they have taken
us by surprise in the last decade
and it takes a little bit more time than
that to start building
other things and there are still many
many other breakthroughs that are
necessary
really all of this is just
now just learning relationships between
things and
going through a machine that is able to
have like critical thinking and things
like that is something
much more complicated can i um can i
can i piggyback off of that wonderful
response
and and and ask holly a question um
holly one of the one of the last things
you left us with was the
uh was the effort to um
to have spawn work in your performances
in real time
in your live performances in real time
um
this seems to be somehow related to the
to the to the difficulties and
and the challenges that that antonio was
just talking about but i wonder if you
could
talk talk to us a little bit more about
how how you begin to close that gap
well it became you know really clear
early on that i wanted to remain
in the driver's seat as a composer so
not to try to outsource that job and i
think that speaks
directly to some of your earlier
questions about the kind of um
the kind of state that ai finds itself
in at the moment i
i don't see it as outperforming me in
that role of
contextualizing the the world around me
and creating
original works that speak to my context
specifically
um so i did decide to kind of try to
focus on live performance but of course
this is a huge challenge because
with sound and processing you have a
kind of latency
and so if you're trying to perform if
you're singing i mean right now i even
there's a latency between my
um my camera and speaking to you and it
and it's already slightly um
uh disorienting but if if this uh
if it was happening in audio on a stage
it would be almost
kind of like an insurmountable challenge
um so the real problem is basically um
computation
time and um yeah just the the
the amount of time before the signal can
be processed before it comes out
the other end so that's what we're
basically working on right now trying to
kind of pre
pre-train models that we can then
perform through that i find really
interesting
but another way that we tried to um
incorporate
some of these ideas into our live
performance before we had the technology
really ready
is we we were looking at um
we were looking at basically how as soon
as anything can become captured in media
like an audio file
video file text file whatever it can
become part of a training canon
so almost as a kind of like public
announcement
we started incorporating uh training
ceremonies into our live concerts
so one of my vocalists would sing a line
and the audience would sing back
and we would record this and we have
recordings from
concerts all over the world with
different audiences and we can then
create
audience models that sound unique to
each room
that was performing because you know
different different countries different
cities have different vocal traditions
different size
crowds et cetera and so
you know as a performer trying to find
ways to
communicate some of the more complicated
ideas to a wider public
through the through incorporating the
public into a training ceremony
but also trying to asceticize the event
and show that
it does actually require kind of um you
know
human labor and human expression in
order to in order to create these
these training sets themselves as a way
to try to communicate that
you know what comes out the other end
isn't just some kind of like
you know random alien um produced
um thing it's something that comes from
human culture and human creation
um so yeah that's why i've focused quite
a bit on
where my training sets have come from a
lot about how we deal with our
shared human archive um one of the
things i really enjoyed about marcus's
talk is that he's really thinking about
things on
a really long time horizon i've really
been thinking about it
on a kind of time horizon of recorded
media so
you know we have this shared human
archive of video and film and photograph
and
you know we can we can reanimate the
dead that we have
an archive of to to kind of do whatever
we want them to do
in the future and so i think it opens up
all kinds of interesting questions about
what we do with that
that shared human archive
so holy one question then when you
um use these recordings
um i mean coming back to this question
of representations then
the way you you want to be the on the
driver's seat of the eye system
so that means the ai system is building
some
some it's decomposing the sound in some
ways building some representation
that you can manipulate and generate new
sounds with
and my question you know when i was
watching your talk was
what what what type of um what type of
representations or what type of
decompositions are you looking for
so that you can actually
control them in the way that you want
well so i've largely been focusing on
performance
techniques so when i say i want to
remain in the driver's seat
i'm largely writing the phrases or the
compositions
and then i'm performing them with my
human voice but i'm able to perform as a
flute or as
whatever kind of you know instrument
that that i've modeled
so that's that's one way or another way
is sometimes i'll write
something and then kind of create
variations
um on that motif
and then interject and pick the parts
that
that are useful and interesting and kind
of move on from there
i think a lot of people who are coming
to music and machine learning that have
maybe
less experience with it they imagine
this kind of
fully automated um
[Music]
black box where you just kind of like
type in an idea and out comes this fully
fleshed
um piece of music and maybe we will get
there um
but you know two things one thing is the
the
um the information that that went to
um to training um in order to get the
piece in and of itself
um that came from somewhere that came
from uh that came from a
human's musicing in space coming up with
uh aesthetic ideas together so that's
one thing that i don't think should be
forgotten or erased
um and the other thing is that it's just
simply not that sophisticated or at
least what i've been working with
is just simply not that sophisticated
yet you know it it has the kind of um
equivalent of the watermark all over the
place and it takes my composer's ear
to go in and remove the watermark or
or leave the watermark but with
intention
and to make whatever i'm creating
have relevance to the world around me
because music isn't just
a combination of of note relationships
it's not like we can just do statistical
analysis
on scores and then fully understand the
the human
emotional aesthetic it's constantly
shifting
and you know whether or not 808 drum kit
or a 707 drum kit
that brings with it an entire history of
um electronic dance music
to it that um that the my computer at
this time
doesn't doesn't understand at all
doesn't understand that kind of history
or that kind of weight
so um yeah i think while it is so
so interesting and so powerful in so
many ways it is also
so limited and requires so much of my
own intervention in order to make
something interesting
and that's why i think it's exciting
actually
um can i add a another problem this is
really really great
holly one other thing that we have found
if we're maybe forgetting the ii
component but just to look to uh natural
systems like a protein or molecules or a
spider web
there are really interesting musical
structures in these and so in some of
the work we have
not not with the use of ai but basically
just mirroring these structures
um into audible sound or musical space
with human choices of course i mean they
have to be made but there are a lot of
really interesting things
um not using ai but just looking to
nature and
you can look at the you know example
work on spider webs where you look at
the
really intricate sounds you can get as
you wander around and the proteins the
folding creating
quite complex counterpoint structures
that are um however not necessarily the
kinds of things that we expect so it
really comes down to the frame as you
were talking i kept thinking you know
there's this
the the moment of expectation um um or
the the history
you mentioned the you know great
examples of the choices of the
instrumentation
and the same goes for the music
generated by natural systems
and i think connects also with what gary
was talking about the bird song you know
these are
not things that we expect and i think
one future evolution i think as we
are become part of the performance and
the observation
as you were doing how linear
performances we
actually become part of the experiment
as listeners and i think the plasticity
that the
species have i think we have to maybe
develop that as as listeners to music as
well and
that opens up a whole new dimension in
understanding and i think it's
in in the world of um people thinking
about composition and how music is
evolving that's more
prevalent of course but if you um look
at a broader public and audience
there's much room to grow i think and i
think that's a great opportunity for for
all of us
to work on and communicate and that
that's why i was talking earlier about
the reference frame
if we begin with this weird reference
frame that nobody understands
we cannot bring the audience to that
point so i oftentimes like to
move the audience from something they
understand and so the arya was an
example for that
and moving away from that and tripling
away from that um and then
showing this other space that opens up
but but i feel yeah also as a teacher
you have to bring the audience from
a teacher class at mit i have to bring
the students from where they are
to where i want them to be or what i
want them to see and i think similarly
in music as well
antonio i'm curious when you hear when
you hear holly
speaking about these um
ritualized entrainments
this this this reminds me of that that
um
uh ingenious and and hilarious passage
from your your presentation with the the
greatest hits
data set where there was almost some
kind of theatrical
presentation of the of the of the
process of producing data
and this is another another theme that i
also
hear hear marcus talking about regularly
about how much of the creativity
going on in in in ai and the arts has to
do with the generation of data sets so
when you when you hear uh these these
thoughts about
the the the plasticity of a public's
perception of a musical tradition
being the medium that's being worked
upon
through the practice of of training an
ai does this
does this um uh incite your your
your imagination as a practitioner
within the uh the uh
the the bowels of the the gary building
over at sea sale
so i i think that the creation of the
training
data sometimes it's a little bit uh
considered like a secondary job
you know there is at least in in in
technical settings
it's uh always a lot more interesting to
develop the algorithms
and the training sets themselves are not
so interesting
i actually think that well not just me i
mean
many people do but training sets are
actually
just as important as the algorithm they
are the question that you want to answer
and the creativity that goes into
producing the data set
sometimes it's just way more important
than the algorithm itself
like for instance what holly was
mentioning about recording uh
different audiences around the world
that type of data
is really interesting and it will create
you know i'm sure it will create
lots of opportunities of producing some
really creative results
the algorithm itself is going to be
secondary
i mean it certainly will change the
outcome but it's going to be kind of
secondary
the the main thing is the data that was
used to train
and and i think that the thinking about
the training sets the questions that you
want to ask
and how that training points towards an
answer
how do you avoid maybe putting too much
of your
biases towards what you think the
answers should be
into how you collect the data i think
that those things are are really
important and i think that uh
you know as you were mentioning
the training data set is a really is
probably one of the
most important part of the creative
process yeah
can i add really something to that
really quick so
this is one of the reasons why we we
like to use ai for data from proteins or
dna or maybe
sounds from spiders is because if we
filter them you through our own brain
and then extract information let's say
for musical inspiration
we're biased by the kind of history we
have in our brain um ai is kind of
for me and i think i think it was
hollywood mentioned in your in your talk
that you start from a blank slate
essentially the ai has never heard
anything they've never heard any music
at all
so the first music that um in my case i
don't have a name for it you have a
great name for it
um but our system um our computer system
um
listens to these hundreds and thousands
of proteins and
um and is has a very abstract knowledge
of these but never heard any other music
and so that sense
it's a great way for us to start from a
clean slate and then
incorporate the human intervention after
that fact so we found it be extremely
useful and important
to avoid the bias from the human
perception
gary were you going to jump in there i i
had i had a thought about your your your
work actually there and i think we might
actually be
edging towards an answer to your
provocation
because if we were to think of the ai
system itself
as being responsible for answering the
question of the generation of meaning
we might be missing out some of these
other observations
about how that algorithm as an analog
for the gene
is always within a context and that
context
has to be something that is transforming
and rendering plastic
the movement of the genetic code through
time
so you have to set in motion as you were
saying gary you have to set
the algorithm in motion through these
acts of contextualization
through these acts of carefully managing
the creation
and preservation of an archive for the
ai to genuinely gain
this radical plasticity of nice
construction and this this is something
that i find so
so fascinating hearing about um
marcus and holly discussing these
various musical archives
because it does really bring to the
foreground
how this entitlement to shared cultural
history is very much at stake in these
discussions
and that that creating some kind of
ground around which to recognize that
the the preservation of these materials
and
and this data and the organization and
structuring of it is really what will
set the up the algorithm in motion and
transform it into a process
to to to elevate it above the emergence
of of
of the function or of optimization so
this these might still be early
beginnings but i think we're
we're hearing in in this discussion that
the importance of composition and
of and of contextualization can never be
uh um
extricated from the design of the
algorithm in that the algorithm
is is nothing without the data set that
that that that
feeds it in other words you know in in
that
in that sense you know when i talk about
uh when i think about an embodied ai um
i think these examples that we've been
hearing today are all and by instances
of
embodiment in ai it is not it is not so
much about a body as it is
as it as it is about a set of contexts
within which
algorithms are unfolding and the data
sets have everything to do with those
contexts are crucial as antonio was just
making clear and as both uh both marcus
and holly's presentations made very very
clear
um uh all of these are
are reflecting human choices i'm not one
to think that we are anywhere close to a
curse while singularity in turn in terms
of
in terms of ai taking over the world and
so on um
but what what it brings home to me again
and again is
is the miraculous nature of even the
simplest life forms that we
that we can think of the the miraculous
nature of the complexity
of their moment-to-moment um context
embodiment and contextualization um and
this is
you know this is this it seems to me
that the challenge of ai
for me as a as an outsider to all of
this fascinated by
but very much an outsider the challenge
is not to create
the machine that thinks like a human
mind the challenge is to
create systems
that are interacting with their
environments in in some degree of com
that approximate some degree of
complexity for even the simplest
biological or uh simplest life forms
interacting with their environments
or so it seems to me but this is just
the question that occupies me i guess
when it comes to ai
and i think it's a question worth
contemplating for many years to come
certainly and with that we we have
reached the the end of our hour-long
time slot so
i just wanted to thank all of you for
these brilliant comments and i think
we've made
a lot of connections here that were that
were nascent in
your talks and i also want to point out
that we've hit upon a number of
of topics that will be coming up
explicitly as the focus of discussion in
the other panels
the question of bias ai and nai will be
addressed later on in in
in the program as will genetic
algorithms and dataset creation
and open systems and even later today
unfolding models
so i invite you all to to join me into
the continuation of these discussions as
we reinforce
enforce the connections to these other
important topics in the discussion
and with that um i i suppose we will
sign off and i would like to
to thank you all again so much for your
for your contributions today
thank you thank you
you